I hope I can help
Necromancy may be legal in Cyrodiil but few will openly admit to practicing it now that the mages guild has banned it
Farewell
May you rest in peace
Oh, yeah play video games
Watch someone else play video. That's right. I'm joining you guys
How stupid can you be
Come on, you guys have been doing it for years. Well, I can't do it oblivion is it's my weakness
This game is just God's gift to earth Thank You. Todd Howard son. Thank you. Fun fact ton Howard was in the Chess Club
Nothing cracks me up like this game. So
Let's just jump into it. The other one got deleted in case anyone is curious what happened to it
But we have a ton of new of Lybian memes. Thanks to bacon who apparently took it upon himself to single-handedly
resurrect this this game
What's going on?
Stop you
Bow or serve your sentence your stolen goods are now forfeit
Then pay with your blood
That's great
This game is too good. I never actually played this game. I just know I love it. That's all
I know Todd Howard god bless your soul and they clearly were way too ambitious with this title
And that's what makes it so goddamn beautiful. I was writing games when I was you know, 12, whatever and
The other kids in the block would say, you know, I'm gonna play quarterback for the Cowboys and I'd be like
I'm gonna make video games and everyone's gonna play
You dork go back to the Chess Club
Who's laughing now?
Yes, I was in the Chess Club
Who's laughing now, I like how it goes from confident to insecure just like that who's laughing now?
Yeah
God bless you Todd, I'm Rena brilliant. I love dogs doesn't everyone everyone does
How do you get that perfect timing god damn it only in Oblivion
I am ready burn it one thing. You need to know about me. I love dogs. Does it every
How does that happen what
in most games these days
It's all about you know
Duck and Cover and and wait for your enemy to come out and then, you know waiting for the right move
It's a lot of waiting is very boring but not nothing speaks like a real action movie nothing tops the matrix times a hundred
Thousand million like the Oblivion combat. Just why Brittani?
You're pathetic
Take that
Goddamn it when you fail at the long range, you just gotta step in on that close range. You're pathetic
Beautiful with that fire now ain't it a surprise
No sign of them they do that in LA a lot it that's Skyrim to be fair, but they do that in life
Just kill someone immediately. That's no sign of him. I guess he's gone
Oh
My god
Does everyone have a dislocated shoulder. What is going on? Wait, what the hell is this Oh,
Todd Howard seduces, you too, Matt. They're mad at Fleetwood Mac's right? It's me
Bethesda's Todd Howard
look, I know you told me not to come around and
Know after we bought skyrim for the Xbox one. You said you were done
At least let me plead my case
No
Poor is the perfect game. It'll have no lobe time. Yeah, did you like that?
No, I can't I'm sorry, I'll save this for later. Yes. Oh great and mighty grand champion. Is there something you need?
Can I carry your weapon shine your boots that road perhaps where it's gonna shoot room in the air. Oh, is it the classic? Oh
Gee, you sure
Okay. Well, I'll be hanging around the arena grounds if you need someone to share the ground you walk on
Absolutely, beautiful. Absolutely
magnificent oh
my god
He just broke his back he's fine he's fine it happens all the time he does that all the time
Happening
This game is so confusing. I think that's why it makes it so good. You see someone run past just now
Well, if you do grab him and yell it bastard stole from me
Did you see thump is that how Americans try to do like Nordic accent is that is that how you see yes, huh?
Racism have you seen anyone in plain sight do you see that man right there?
You know the action is very exciting of in oblivion and Skyrim, of course
But nothing really entices me and immerses me like the dialogue that really makes me feel like I'm part of the world
It feels like real dialogues real people real communication
How goes it?
I've been better. I hope things get better. Oh
Hello
How are you today?
I've been better. How about you?
I've been better. What's the news from the other parts of Tamriel?
nothing, and I'd like to talk about
So long
Be seeing you at first. I thought it was the same guy. Just talking to himself
But it's clearly the same voice actor for these two characters interacting. I've been better. How are you been better?
It's as long as like this same person or something. It's incredible. I already show this one, but it's so funny
This guy's an absolute an absolute menace to society, I don't know you
Know it's this about. I don't know you and I don't
They they test this game at all and I don't care
Okay, we get it thank you that is literally me at school to everyone
I don't know you I don't care to know you Thank You Pat sir. The voice acting is just impeccable lady. Amber
Knox has hired a new captain lady. Amber. Knox has hired a new captain of the guard
Todd did that intentionally
I know he did Spriggans nature's Guardians my foot
Mean things they'll curse you or they might call a bear to tear you apart
Spriggans nature's Guardians my foot mean things they'll curse you or they might call a bear to tear you apart
wow, it's so nice to see a game that really
Articulates all the points that they want to say. It feels like I'm talking to a real person
Don't you feel it too smash like if you feel it, too
thank you something that's really innovative for video games is the fact that
Characters will actually remember their interaction with you like that one Lord of the Rings game
For example, that definitely does not occur in oblivion
I mean oblivion really lives up to his name because it seems like a blue everyone just having amnesia
I'm captain of the castle guard and Deon is captain of the town guard
It's simple I don't care what goes on in town. That's Dion's problem
Goodbye you're the gray fox
You're under arrest for for for all kinds of stuff. You're wanted dead or alive. I'm i'm choosing dead
I'll make captain for this. Oh great
Man down he was just a captain that wanted to be captain. So sad only asking for enough to
Thank you later. Gather
Blessings of the shadow upon
Thank you, sir, sir get blessings of akatosh upon ye, thank you kind sir
Blessings of the shadow upon ye blessing upon you for smashing like on this video. Thank you. Can't there
He was here a second ago you
I've seen your kind before you've got blood on your hands
Keep your blade sheath you murdering bastard, or I'll put you down myself
Stay safe citizen say saves our dark times
You just murdered some wine, how could you do this spell looks dangerous keep your distance
Damnit will we ever get games like this anymore? I doubt it your money or your money or your life
You're smarter than you look seems fair they have braids in his hair
Take it it's worthless to me anyway
The whole video of me just
Goddamnit, I laughed at that how does that happen?
You see this highwayman at existential crisis after you stole from him
You see he makes a living stealing from others and yet he himself was just robbed
You can't say you were in the wrong since he's done worse. I mean, yeah, I guess he's just calling us worthless
Isn't he because he was comparing our life to the money
Take it it's worthless to me. Anyway. Yeah. It's oddly like sad
But of course the top of the cake the cake of the cake the cake inside the cake the guards, of course
Nothing beats the AI
Anyway, okay oblivion really has mastered AI it doesn't get any cleverer the cleverer really smarter than this. What is it?
Very subtle
Stop right there criminal scum
Nobody breaks the law and my watch I'm confiscating your stolen goods now pay your fine or it's off to jail
Then pay with your blood see my mascara watch out
Take the fuckin do well sir officer. She says all flesh and no fury. I can't tell you
It keeps stealing. So it's a perfect long live the Empire what's going on?
It's all over law breaker your sprees at an inner I'll take any stolen. Could you have the next move is yours?
Pay your fine or I'll haul you away
Then pay with your blood
It's all over Anakin I have the high ground
Alright, that's it guys going right to subscribe to bacon. I'll link his channel down below
he is still uploading these I wouldn't be able to make this video without it and
Honestly, it's so funny. I I it's kind of weird
I I feel like I shouldn't play the game because I have this expectation in my head that every interaction is gonna be like this
Now because all I've ever seen from it, but if you guys wanted me to play the game
I think I would be up for I think it could be fun
I don't know. But if you enjoyed this video smash like and I'll see you guys tomorrow. Hope this video. It was enjoyable
I'm sure it was. Thank you very much. Goodbye
brofist